last week we heard the news that British
actor Benedict Cumberbatch got engaged
yeah it's been reported that he flew to
his fiance's mother's house to ask for
her hand in marriage wait wait
so that engagement is still on then it's
definitely still on yeah it's still on
yeah okay because sometimes people take
the weekend to think about these things
and they realize they made a huge
mistake yeah the Andi the engagement is
very much still on Benedict Cumberbatch
says he's in love well then I guess I
don't need my Benedict Cumberbatch Smaug
anymore
okay Andy thanks for playing along Andy
what why you so upset about this I'm not
upset
I just a fan of his work I respect his
craft in the way he conducts himself in
the public eye that's all so I guess
that's why you always have his headshot
on your podium yeah well when someone
says xoxoxo usually it means something
Andy I'm sorry I didn't know this was
such a touchy subject for you I
apologize I just need to be alone right
now Andy come back
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oscar for Andy Richter I say
[Applause]
you